guess I was saying yo I'm fighting a
real boxer he's a professional boxer 9-0
right I don't know listen with boxing
like the earlier fights in your career
you're fighting what are called tomato
cans people that are loose there is and
he's not the only person that has done
this every boxer has done this Floyd did
it like every pro boxer now the question
is
is this his full-time job no he's done
other things I think he's been in like a
business and nightlife Etc so we don't
know how padded the record is but you
can make the same thing about Tommy Fury
so they set you up with whatever so we
can't really tell exactly how good he is
but I think that was the idea what this
fight is I'm gonna fight a pro and beat
him Jake tried to fight a pro couldn't
beat him I'm gonna do it so the question
is does he go and fight I don't think
there's any point in fighting this guy I
know no no no no no no like you kind of
have to
if you were a actual fighter you do but
if you're fighting in the purely like
entertainment part of it yeah like
nobody they're not going for Bill yeah